welcome everyone to our assessing
students with wsj this will be our
assessment tool demo as part of our
seminar series my name is Lesley
Bedingfield and I'm a marketing manager
on the student memberships team here at
The Wall Street Journal I appreciate all
of you joining me today I actually look
after the professor marketing on our
team and my goal is to make sure that
I'm offering professors tools that
really make it easy for them to
incorporate The Wall Street Journal into
their courses so trying to make it as
easy as possible I'm constantly
evaluating our tools and the products
that we offer for professors so any
feedback you may have is greatly
appreciated I've included my email here
if you'd like to reach out to me about
any questions or tools that we go over
whether it's the assessment tool or
anything else feel free to reach out to
me my email is lesley dot Bedingfield at
Dow Jones comm it's right up here on the
screen I just want to go over a few
housekeeping notes before we go ahead
and get started
the session today will last about 30
minutes we will go over questions at the
end you should see a little chat box in
your go-to webinar panel that can allow
you to ask any questions that might come
up as I'm going through things you are
all on mute so definitely use that chat
box and I'll be monitoring that so that
we can answer any questions if for any
reason we run out of time and I can't
answer all the questions on the call I
will be sure to reach out to you we are
also recording this webinar so feel free
to watch and we will follow up with a
recording in the next few days so that
you can have this or share around with
any of your colleagues it does take a
little bit we have to coordinate with
the newsroom to get the video hosted so
please be patient with me I will be sure
to follow up once I have the video and
let's just go ahead and start so I just
wanted to give you a quick overview for
anyone who might not be familiar with
the Wall Street Journal we really pride
ourselves on the coverage that the
newsroom offers they do a great job of
covering breaking news and in-depth
analysis across a variety of industries
and have even been considered one of the
most trustworthy news sources by several
different polls including Reuters
Institute YouGov poll economist Pew
Research and so much more and the
Simmins news media trust index actually
ranked The Wall Street Journal first and
it was the only newspaper within the top
five so that's something that I on the
marketing team along with the newsroom
are very proud of and I know the
newsroom really strives to be offering
great comprehensive and balanced news
stories and then specifically as we're
talking about education and professor
and student memberships for Wall Street
Journal the student provides or the
students can get a lot out of the Wall
Street Journal as well you know in
addition to being that trusted new
source that I just mentioned it's really
great for getting students in the habit
of keeping up with current events we
also curate career and lifestyle content
for students so they can learn more
about topics such as loan repayment
salary negotiation email etiquette lots
of career advice that can help them
they're all Wall Street Journal
memberships for professors and students
also include our wsj Plus access which
can give students access to exclusive
events to attend in person discussions
or perhaps start networking with
potential industry professor
professionals right now students can
access our student membership through
either a university sponsored program or
by purchasing an individual student
subscription we do offer a special price
for that individual student subscription
of four dollars per month
anyone who's interested in learning more
whether you're a student or a professor
you can go to our education site
education wsj.com to learn more about
either our University sponsored program
or individual membership we also have
discounted membership for professors and
again if you have any questions about
those feel free to reach out to me and I
can direct you to the right place so now
I kind of want to dive into our actual
tool the assessment tool so I figured I
can just show you our little demo so
I'll go over creating a class signing in
and what the student view looks like and
again this is being recorded and if you
have any questions feel free to put them
in the chat box and we'll do our best to
answer them at the end of the call and
again any lingering questions I'll make
sure I follow up offline with you
so our assessment tool is available at
wsj assessment comm we try to make it as
easy as possible to remember I've
already logged in here but let me pull
up what it looks like if you are new to
registering so this is what the sign-in
screen will look like if you don't yet
have an account you'll want to register
as a professor so you can select that
and fill this out we do verify that you
are a professor so there could be a
little bit of a delay between
registering and getting verification but
once we verify that you are an
instructor who should have access to a
you know wall street journal quizzes
with questions and answers we will send
you a notification email that you are
now approved and you can go ahead and
sign in and then you'll always want to
be signing in on this page with your
email and password that you set up for
students you will invite students to
register for the specific class that you
set up so they can also log in on this
page once they've already gone through
the registration process but they have
to follow your link
and I'll show you that as we go through
the setup process and any student who
might you know see that you are using
this on your syllabus and be really
eager we do provide a little reminder to
any student who's trying to register
without that link that they will need a
unique link from their professor so now
I'll just dive back into my demo
dashboard so again this is the page I
see when I first log in as a professor
we have a quick snapshot dashboard and
that provides an overview of you know
your courses your students your schools
your sections things of that nature that
can be a really easy way to just dive
into your specific areas and get a
snapshot and then there's also this menu
on the left-hand side which will take
you to any area you need to navigate to
so to first start off when you're
creating a class you'll need to create
your course so whatever course you're
teaching you'll want to create that here
and then if you teach multiple sections
of that course you'll be able to add
that as well under a section so I'll
just start you can add on this
right-hand side the add course blue
button will allow you to create that
course so we'll just do marketing 80
demo and we'll say this is a Tuesday
Thursday class and then I'll just select
so you should already have your school
show up through your registration
process you can also select the
disciplines you are interested in
receiving quizzes for as you're signing
up and you can always add more if you
decide that you want new ones by going
over to your account and adding
disciplines there and then we'll say
that we're doing this for our spring 20
some of sir so I can save that and now
I've successfully added this course so
once I go into that
we can just go ahead and if I want to
make any changes I can hit the three
dots on the right hand side that allows
me to edit delete or check my grades a
report right there so we can see that's
all right there and then if I want to
just dive into that I need to make any
changes we can edit and then we can go
to sections so I can add a section to
that course so this will be Tuesday
Thursday and then I'll select that
course that I just made save that and
now I have my overall course as well as
this specific section so again if you
only teach one section you'll just have
to make one course one section if you
teach multiple sections of the same
course you can add them here as well and
again if you need to make any changes
you can always scroll to the right of
any course section test anything like
that and bring up the menu there so we
can have these three dots and they'll
show view students view assigned tests
edit if I need to make any changes view
test results and then invite students so
that's very important since I just
created this section and I don't have
any students in my course yet I want to
hit invite students so this will
pre-populate with the info available
from the course and so section I have
just selected and so I can either invite
students in two ways so I can input
their email addresses and send them an
email
we have suggested text right here so
that will automatically send an email
through the system out to your students
if you'd like to invite them through
your own email system or put the link on
your syllabus or LMS you can also just
copy and paste the URL right here so we
can go ahead and copy so now I have that
link
copied that I can share out with my
students so I'm just going to save that
quickly for being able to show you the
student view and then once you submit
that you can go ahead and send out the
email or again you can copy and paste
the link to invite students as you
choose and then once you have students
you will be able to see them populated
with in your section so again you can
get a high-level overview as I just
created that I don't have any students
but you can always view all the students
within that section and view their test
results and again if you need to invite
them to that specific section go ahead
and select that invite to send the link
again and you can always track and see
who students are have been invited but
our pending as well as those who have
actually joined your section so that's
great to be able to keep track of
invites especially at the start of the
semester if you want to see an overview
of all your students you can also just
select students so the student section
on the left hand side will be an
overview of all students whereas within
the section you'll be looking
specifically at those students in that
section so you can see here my one test
student that I've created is registered
and approved and as I mentioned if
there's any invites that are out pending
you would be able to see that as well
now if you want to a sign a test you'll
want to go to the test sections let me
just bring up my marketing since I have
my marketing demo class so what we have
here is a list of all the unassigned
quizzes that I can go ahead and assign
to my specific sections so each week we
have professor contributors who create
quizzes for us so these are subject
matter experts who are professors in
their field they read The Wall Street
Journal each week and they select just
articles that they
think relate closely to their
disciplines and create true false and
multiple choice questions and then we
publish those quizzes weekly and so
those will all be available in this sort
of test Bank area where you can see all
your unassigned tests and then you'll
also be able to customize quizzes if
you'd like to add or remove any
questions from what we have had the
professors make for you and those are
available in nine disciplines everything
from accounting business law leadership
ethics and you can see those as you're
signing up and if you have any questions
please let me know so once you have this
test Bank you'll want to go over to
again to the right-hand corner to bring
up these three dots and that's how you
can add a test to your my test file so I
can say add test and then I confirm that
I want to add this and then what that
does is that brings it so that I get the
little notification test has been added
successfully and we see this check box
appear that allows me to select it if I
want to assign it to my section as is I
can go ahead and just simply select
assign to section if I want to do a
little previewing which I imagine many
of you would like to see the content you
can go ahead and just hover over the
menu and now you can see that this has
add question edit test delete test or
download if you have to provide a paper
test for any of your students that is
also an option so I just want to edit
test so this allows me to change the
name so you can change the name to
whatever works best for you we always
just default to the test name discipline
and date to make it easy to find so
again you can edit the description as
you see fit
or leave it to what has been
pre-populated by our professor
contributors then you are allowed to see
the questions and answers that exist for
this quiz
and if you want to change anything you
are able to do that as well again it's
going to be these three dots on the
right hand side that allow you to make
changes so you can simply delete a
question if that's not one that you want
on your test you can also go ahead and
edit a test or edit a question if you'd
like to change it slightly and do so
there so you would be allowed to let's
say you like this question but maybe you
want it to be true false so you just go
in and edit and reword it a little bit
to change it there so what you would be
allowed to do is change that you can
also see the article that the questions
are referencing if you want to provide
an explanation for your answers to your
students you can go ahead and do that as
well under the edit portion now if you
want to add new questions you can do so
as well so we have two options here so
assign questions will bring you up the
test Bank questions that exist for
marketing so it wouldn't necessarily be
this week's quizzes but it will be all
the questions that have been written by
our contributor so let's say you like
something that was written from back in
December it's relevant for your course
you can go ahead and add that so you can
see here any one that you would like to
add and go ahead and just the green
checkmark means it's already in your
test but you can go back and you can see
that now we're getting into later weeks
so we can go ahead and add it and add
those so a simple checkmark will add it
successfully to your test there's also
the option for you to write your own
question and add it to the test so that
would be add a new question and that
will take you to the area where you can
add in a whole new question for yourself
just for your students for that specific
section that you're assigning to so you
can fill this out you'll have to put the
article
and title that you are linking to topics
and keywords are really organizational
helpers for you as a professor to be
able to find these questions at a later
date if you will want to be reusing them
and then you'll want to select question
type again either multiple choice or
true/false fill in the questions and
answers as appropriate there and then
you can simply add the question so once
I am happy with my test I'm going to say
done for all my edits and then that
allows me to go ahead and assign it to
my section so I will select that assign
to section and then I am able to choose
the section that I want to sign it
assign it to confirm and now here's a
couple of options that you get to choose
as the professor for every test you
assign so would you like to provide the
article links that would be a yes so
that students can read the articles
before they're quizzed on them there's
also a few options here if you want to
try and prevent cheating so you can show
the questions in a random order to
students so they'll all be getting
different question orders and you can
also choose whether the answer shows up
at the time of completion or at after a
certain due date so if you want all your
students to have to wait until after the
due date to see the answers you can
select that and then if you'd like it to
be a time-based quiz you can also select
that as well as the time amount that
students have to complete it and just a
note for any like a DA compliances you
can also go to the individual student
level and change that if you need to
provide an untimed test for any student
so you get the notification that your
test has been assigned successfully and
then you would see it in the assigned
area believe have a couple of different
courses and disciplines so we can go
ahead and see that I currently have the
test that I just assigned to my sections
I have not invited any of my students so
that is a reminder that you'll want to
make sure to do that for any students
and then I'm quickly going to show the
gradebook option so as you are going
through you can get grades for your
students and download those as an excel
file or CSV file in order to import
those into the gradebook that you use at
your school so I'm just going to reset
that right now because I don't have any
students in my course and then we'll
just go high level ethics so you'll want
to select at least to the course level
and I don't have students right now but
you would be able to see the report here
and like I said you'll be able to export
that in a CSV or excel file and be able
to either get an individual student or
Section grade report for your quizzes
now I want to go over quickly to the
student view just so you can see what
that looks like as well so again I'm
going to grab that invite link that I
had copied earlier again you can either
invite students directly through this
link or through the email process
so this is what the student registration
looks like if they already have an
account if two professors are using it
they can go ahead and just click here to
login I do already have a demo student
account set up so I'm going to do that
let's see if I remember my student
perfect okay so this is what the student
dashboard will look like and I can see
if I have any tests to do any tests that
are overdue as well as my completed
tests if I have scores available if the
instructor has made those available
after the due date I'll also be able to
see my results and understand how well
I'm doing
in a course and again for students it's
pretty simple I'm just able to see what
is assigned to me and due dates from
what my professor sets up so now I will
see if there are any questions okay I
know we have a few more minutes so again
if you have any questions just feel free
to use the check box or the chat box I'm
sorry to put your questions there again
there will be a recording available for
you to watch of this to go through the
process you can also reach out to me
again my email is Leslie dot Bedingfield
at Dow Jones comm and you can also visit
the professor page on our education site
to go ahead and learn more about our
subscription options and find your rep
I'm not seeing any questions come in so
I will go ahead and end our call today
and if any questions do come up feel
free to reach out to me thank you so
much